not sure if it was cheating or pollyanna
it's because it's because of what jada
chose to put on red table talk yeah
about choice again this thing of like
celebrity i find it so strange i'm like
but it's the same thing if you if you
like it might happen on uh like the
reason we look at celebrities it's
because they represent like our normal
life
so like like for example i know a lot of
guys that have trouble in like custody
like getting custody of the kids and so
when kanye was going through that it
kind of represents like part of like a
problem in society because if a
billionaire can't get custody of his
kids like what does that say about
society right same thing like if if you
wife a 304 that like talks
right on online it might not happen at
like a global scale but like you can
still embarrass your dude in your
community you know what i'm saying like
it might it might not happen at that big
of a level but these people like they
represent what's happening in society
just at like a global scale does that
make sense yeah i suppose i just i
actually
respect them for the fact that um
i mean she wouldn't speak on it on a
podcast
unless he was happy for her to do so i
think we we could all agree that they
have a stable enough relationship you
think you think she listens
oh my god no she she just said that she
didn't agree with the slap no no no no
i'm saying is in i
when they talk about when she talks
about like the the kind of relationship
that they have and like their open
relationship and things when she's
spoken on that right they had they had
talks they had august on red table talk
who's august
the guy the guy that she essentially
cheated with like 20 years younger but
interesting i'll be honest i think judy
is going to do whatever she wants to do
but yeah i think my point is like i
in a sense respect the fact that
these people
regardless of what people think of jada
because i think she
gets a lot of flack i don't know all of
the insider goss by the way i'm up at
the other yeah but
i think that i respect them for the fact
that will is a is is clearly standing up
and saying actually you know we have
this kind of relationship or you know
we've we've had a bit of an open
relationship and i still love my wife
and things and i think okay fair enough
regardless of what i think of the
dynamic of your relationship i
appreciate the fact that that this
person is going i still stand with my
wife i think that's
i think that's that is a good thing but
i think like going back to the original
point i think that
uh i think it's just a i think it's just
a bit of a shame that like that that
we've you how
like the the way that we
view our respect of men versus women
that it's that it's not a similar thing
in the in our respect of men is is
deemed on you know
respectable things like you know
are you intelligent
you know are you ambitious these good
qualities and women are reduced down to
have you slept with lots of men well
it's not reduced down to it's like
that's easier
how much harder it is to be a dude
you just have to not get fat okay as a
girl not get fat not sleep with too many
people and you'll you'll find a husband
but like men if they want to get a woman
they have to make a lot of money they
have to go to the gym
they have to like there's a long list of
[ __ ] that like women look for
i think guys do too and i think it's i
think as we move away that's not true
that's not true no because statistically
like like if you if you survey women
like i could point out study after study
after study showing you that's not true
because if you look at dating app swipes
men swipe right like 50 of the time and
on top of that like they serve it men if
you go on a first date with a girl she
has 80 of the things you look for would
you go on a second date men said yes
women said no like women are pickier
it's much harder for a man to like get
girls than it is for girls to get guys
even even as even in commitment terms
yeah i think in terms of on the surface
level of what what do people want and
again going back to that thing of
abundance yeah but i think
every guy i know every single res like
guy who i go oh we're friends we're
these are these are guys who i really
respect
none of them like of course they could
go okay yeah i would maybe swipe right
on her but none of them would stay if
she had no personality no ambition no
hobbies no interest sure i agree sure a
guy a guy with options you're correct
like the guys that can will but like my
point is
like we're complaining about this double
standard right but it's like it's not
even that bad
to be honest it might like i think it's
much harder for men on the other end
because they have to like build up to be
something that women want unless you're
just born really good looking and tall
i think
some men are lucky
shout out to a shout out to chris
when you came to my channel you said
when you're dating apps like
you look at most of the girls you go oh
yeah like with most girls you can see
something attractive that you go yeah i
just go on a date with you you look at
the guys and you're like most guys
you're like what the [ __ ] is this you
even said that so it's like
and
so here's the question do you think you
apply a different standard to men than
you do to women
when you're dating them
no i think it's a thing of am i
do they have a good personality are they
physically attractive i i look for the
same things the same traits
but i think my my point when we were
speaking before is i think there are
objectively more pretty women in the
world than there are good looking man so
do you like a guy who's taller than you
and we also spoke about this and i again
i've dated people who were short like
someone who was actually shorter than me
and i've dated people who are all [ __ ]
up than me what like would you prefer a
guy who's taller
oh fine don't cap like what i mean is
imagine you've got you've got the guy
he's got amazing personalities right
there's one version of him where he's
six foot one and there's one version of
him when he's five foot four
who are you gonna choose
that's actually that's a really
interesting question are you saying it
has no berry i actually don't know no i
actually don't know do you care for
girls taller than you
i actually prefer girls who are taller
than me yeah you do i actually prefer
taller girls yeah have you dated more
yeah i tend to prefer girls who are
taller than me maybe i would with guys
say that maybe if that was a side by
side i don't think and i don't think
it's a bad thing because you know i've
got quite a few friends who are bi as
well and it's like
they they probably they apply a
different standard to men than they do
for women
and i think ugly i would agree i do i i
would say there's more attractive girls
than guys yeah
um
but there is a burden there is a higher
burden of performance on men
in terms of
to in terms of being attractive in
general in comparison to women find 80
of men unattractive
yeah i can i can relate to that yeah do
you find eight percent of women
unattractive
no but then i feel like my attraction to
women is
how do i put this but do you see what
i'm saying when i'm saying like it's
much harder for men in dating
like in just like oh like yeah
for sure in terms of like and again
talking about like abundance and things
like that i think
because if there are all of these pretty
women and i think they go oh my god he's
the he's the top guy
i think for sure but i think again a lot
of that is reducing it down to dating
out but then so then could you
understand like when men like really
don't have a ton of standards that it's
okay like like that they might say like
that that's a standard for them is that
either a low body count or no only hands
yeah and again like i completely i'm
like if that's if that for you is a deal
breaker i respect that that's fine
you're allowed to have that opinion
but for me it's just more about
but why do you have that opinion one and
one in three men are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the last year i think
that's under
days
isn't it i don't know
one in three men are either a virgin or
haven't had sex in the past year
that's brutal yeah that's brutal
i'm gonna read some super chats really